c'est évidemment oui parce que c'est un
collège privé catholique les parents ont
fait un choix alors moi je reste je suis
pas forcément d'accord avec cette
interdiction mais je comprends que des
parents qui fait ce choix là de mettre
les enfants dans un collège catholique
soit dérangé par des choses non mais si
mais attendez je peux venir très
doucement là
en Côte
d'Ivoire
même si tu joues tout ça regrettable je
peux enlève le frein
c'est pas le fromage je vais enlever tu
vas voir
je trouve ça je comprends que des
parents qui ont fait un choix donc de
laisser catholiques et tu vas dire
combien de fois en fait
pour Sophie on va voir si elle est après
ce que tu dis bah bon allez vas-y sois
bon donc je finis ce que je voulais en
train de dire je trouve je trouve ça
regrettable qui est où ce choix
d'interdire ce film mais quand des
parents ont un choix de mettre leurs
enfants dans un collège catholique je
pense avec je pense avec des avec des
convictions tu dois faire
faire attention à toi
[Applaudissements]
donc avec certaines convictions je ne
partage pas forcément je comprends pas
tu as dit quatre fois la même chose mais
tu m'arrêtes tout le temps mais fini
[Rires]
je peux entendre que les parents soient
choqués par cette diffusion là merci
beaucoup donc la France c'était par
cette diffusion là
tu sais quoi tu dis un mot un mot je
fais le tour je vais pouvoir
rester là déjà
tu as une chambre en formicale
vraiment l'émission elle sera finie
allez c'est bon allez vas-y Gilles
jamais vu une telle nullité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je comprends à demi-mots que tu dis
parce que tu parles pas parce que là
c'est un film génial et je trouve que
justement ce serait merveilleux de le
faire regarder à des enfants pour
comprendre la différence la différence
de genre en fait dans les cours d'école
c'est toujours pareil on se on se moque
de la différence et je trouve que la
différence justement à cet âge là c'est
formidable de l'être ouais je pense que
c'est pas mal en plus
c'est un sujet sérieux je pense que le
collège et la 6e c'est ni le lieu ni
l'âge pour ce genre de film aux enfants
ça va leur faire se poser des questions
qui se serait peut-être jamais posé et
je pense que c'est un sujet tellement
sensible on le règle pas en disant bah
tiens on va montrer un film à tous les
enfants vous pouvez changer de sexe
quand vous le voulez
pour le faire
manger libre bravo on on voudrait avoir
madame parce qu'elle a pas beaucoup
parlé
mais c'est ça le problème est beaucoup
plus vaste Daniel le problème est
moderne plus c'est vraiment une mouvance
en ce moment et dans le monde entier il
y a des par exemple on en a parlé des
spectacles de Drag Queen dans les écoles
des parents il y a des spectacles de
drop Queen
ce film date de 2000 ans en 2014 il y a
déjà eu ces pelé ce genre de polémiques
de parents ça a été refus ça a été
retiré du programme et des
pédopsychiatres à l'époque j'ai lu des
articles de l'époque ont expliqué qu'en
fait il ne fallait pas penser qu'un
enfant était un adulte miniature oui
et leur répondre à des questions qui ne
se posent pas donc c'est trop tôt pour
moi
c'est trop tôt maintenant
ce qui s'est passé c'est de la censure
terrible genre
la question du genre
écoute vu la prestation que tu as faite
ferme ta gueule ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
il est beau
le minimum de dignité c'est vrai que tu
rentres chez toi barre-toi
[Applaudissements]
casse-toi calme-toi la sortie c'est par
là que tu as dit
30 ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Cyril c'est une question majeure qui
proposait qu'il faut montrer à tous les
écoliers à tous les jeunes si on évite
cette question on aura des jeunes
névrosées à 18 ans et là c'est si un
groupe muscule extrême droite les
intégristes catholiques qui poursuivent
ce film qui pisse
on ne doit pas censurer ce film
avait protesté contre la diffusion sur
Arte
c'est tes enfants c'est pas merci
pour les écoles
sur Arte c'est parfait
c'est un site qui s'appelle riposte
catholique qui se présente comme un site
de réinformation catholique je sais pas
ce que ça veut dire et c'est eux qui
mettent la pression donc c'est pas les
parents c'est une association bien
précise qui et il y a quelques personnes
majeures ne sont peut-être pas à
soumettre aux mineurs
ce côté là vous allez
dis ce que tu voulais dire depuis tout à
l'heure
pourquoi entièrement d'accord je trouve
que Guillaume
c'est vrai non mais j'ai entièrement
d'accord
donc tu te suis entièrement d'accord je
suis entièrement d'accord pour qu'on
réponde aux questions se pose les
enfants
tu l'as vu le film ou pas
[Rires]
absolument génial de changer de genre le
film est sur la cruauté des enfants il
est mais non mais bien sûr il y a un
moment on n'est pas là pour faire des
trucs cinéma
tout personne n'a vu le film donc est-ce
qu'on a besoin de regarder les films les
filles parce qu'on a besoin de regarder
des films à l'école non à l'école c'est
fait pour travailler
c'est bon là c'est bon là les les c'est
bon on peut voir oui bravo voilà je suis
voilà bravo je suis complètement
d'accord